it's lawa time that's my intro that's my
new intro grab your favorite G fuel and
let's freakin do this I've seen this fan
art and it's goddamn perfect thank you
so much Buffalo pillow me and the boys
ready to give the news with Papa Gloria
is it me or is Papa Gloria after using
into some sort of monster oh okay
wait sir Paulo did the art is that right
oh it's pelo that did it
ah that's not a retweet I love it i
uncover the mystery of pewdiepies window
cleaner what the truth can never be
stopped Felix Oh
our dear PewDiePie thinks he's so smart
you goddamn right by not showing the
friend of his window cleaner our stalker
Felix challenge accepted
what the hell is this first analyze the
footage blue part white part curvy
bottle solutely what is this let's go go
blue window cleaning spray now that's
not it nope Windex nope Ajax actually
spray oh oh
bottle shape matches but not the color
oh gosh let's a delicious look come on I
literally show the logo under present
bright colour first letter is W hmm this
match so far is window lean let's Google
their products of God oh god no and you
think you had me figured out huh so yeah
you have too much spare time
congratulations you did it
doesn't even look like that wake up
sheeple idiots Papa Gloria is still
alive you're sleeping yeah
what if Papa Gloria killed Mary Hamm and
then this guy's herself as Mary ham to
avoid suspicion
bra wait what did Papa Gloria killed
Matt Hamm and the disguise ourselves man
oh my god
now this is impressive first the windows
stuff and now this you guys should
become detective or something Jesus
Christ this is beautiful I wish this is
real so much is this real yes of course
it is huge video quality okay here we go
again
Mars yes this meme is never gonna die
isn't it here I have the perfect quality
and people still complain shaking my
head my head he's dead
one light equals five push-ups please I
really need this haha what is that oh
it's 49,000 Jesus Christ what is that
250,000 that's not too bad it's gonna be
[ __ ] rip dude he's gonna have abs on
top of his abs now this is some original
content what mr. B's uploaded this last
to stop kissing wince 25 grand challenge
Jesus Christ dude it'd be fun even mr.
B's did this try the Russian Roulette
challenge with six bullets in the gun
okay alright okay let's calm down
planted a bunch about nine hundred
little trees in this pasture it ain't
much but it's honest work
well done soldier well done
this channel will keep going in 50 years
and we'll do an update then update on
the trees that's amazing I like that
keep planting trees goddamnit what are
you doing right now stop wasting your
time on cleaners and start planting
trees god dammit my friend recently
passed and he was a huge fan of peopIe
this is a video of him back when the tea
servicing was big I hope to honor him by
getting him until oh I
I don't like you mr. t nothing personal
kid sorry to hear by you bro Apple
announces 99 Hunt oh yeah Jesus Christ a
thousand dollar monitor stand the
Chinese guy who made him for zero point
$12 absolutely incredible
why you don't want to stand that looks
like a cheese grater what why does it
cost a thousand though honestly like
what what is it made of gold very true
scientists students need heed I see
where this is going
need a full eight hours of sleep schools
we don't do that here
they need homework you see they can't
just do schoolwork at school they need
to also do schoolwork at home all
weekends when there's no school oh no no
I went to a Montessori School which is
based on the concept that you're
supposed to study yourself at school
like we got an hour a day in school for
us to do homework and stuff like that
but that just led to teachers giving us
more homework because we always go hey
there's no time for us to do the
homework and they're like oh is there I
believe that is an hour every day every
teacher went that so we school sucks
smash like if you think school sucks too
school didn't even teach me how to buy a
Lambo like SM H man PT PI deserves
proper recognition
oh that's goddamn right okay 2019 s
YouTube rewind will be worse than 2018 s
why since YouTube will most likely have
something related to teasers but not
foods that hurts me you guys think of
everything don't you and that's a fact
that's alright we'll put grind Eidolon
and Kitty together it won't matter
explanation time she's like the best
she's my favorite I love Mary ham
alright let's hear it now this is
Christ's beauty pie actually killed Papa
Gloria because he has a crush on no I
just think she's kind of hot dog ate
shirt say what you want about her but
you cannot deny the fact that Mary Hamm
looks hella sexy hold on what about Mars
yet okay alright let's calm down let's
remind them Felix of this we want the
story after
my balls healed I broke my peepee one
day I'll tell you about it this is a lie
I never broke my peepee reported so
weird that this group is interested in
this man's genitalia what me posting
only half the meme yeah okay I got it
oh my god is it here redditors my a plus
that was amazing the right underneath
each other - that's awesome
sorry brother it needed to be done when
you find out your brother watches works
alright so long partner
I'm with my girl and I see the boys
that's not a girl I'm so confused
kind of thick though did you get a
girlfriend yes what did it cost the boys
come on come on as long as you're not
Pippi whipped then it's fine I take your
meme and I raise you one IKEA boy normal
DNA hard as DNA
Felix DNA oh it's IKEA I got it you
think that's funny you blatantly racist
look at my sis DNA how could you say
this about me marry ham pad oh god what
is it now when the sub - Pierce meme
ended and I realized I can't change my
name oopsie did Mary ham review you in
meme review yes what did it cause
they're boys all of them I think this is
one of those means that will stick
around using the Drake damnit Drake
formula I need to review this good meme
sorry this frickin mean using a new
template with houses for boots can I
take in fact that's ten out of ten thank
you that's funny Mary Hamm promoting a
scam app meaning she'll probably get
terminated
I can't believe Mary Hamm did this I'm
poppin Laurie oh all right well the next
point I guess I have to address this not
a meme but there's a lot of people
commenting on peebs recent video and I
thought I'd send it here - this got
30,000 up votes and it says don't
download NIM says the app it's
advertised it takes all of you data and
monitors it even after you install it
now this is just demonstrably false okay
abs can't do that if you aren't in Seoul
it so
it's already spreading misinformation
just in the title literally every single
social media tracks the way nemesis does
it's a social media app everyone seems
so freaked out about it and there was
this this top boat saying that they
broke down the apk like the the file on
Android and it showed what it does and
the really scary part is that they use
the following permissions ordered by
danger from high to low the fact that it
starts itself when the phone powers on
any app that has notifications does this
okay what else it requests install
packages can request the users to
install additional apps and software
literally any app with ads does this we
do it in tuber simulator as well hey you
want to download this other app that we
have PewDiePie of legend of the brofist
if you don't want to do it just click no
it asks you to do all this permission to
get accounts literally reads which
accounts you are logged into Google
that's the same thing Android permission
camera what a social media network wants
to use my camera Oh what do you want to
look at me like come on guys listen
they're not paying me to defend these
allegations but you're just going off
rumors if you're worried about your
privacy by all means don't sign up to a
social media network I thought it
sounded like a cool idea if you guys
didn't like the promo and you know like
the sponsorship I'm sorry I mean I will
try to do better to find ads that you
like but it's also everyone seems so
protective of me my hands are was so
like oh we need to protect them from all
the media stuff and then you're
spreading misinformation to make it look
like I'm promoting a scam
obviously that makes it look way worse
same thing with D live like D live is
not a scam
there's no proof to show that but it's a
bunch of rumors spread around being like
oh it's promoting a scam again I have no
equity I have no reason to defend it
besides the fact that it's
misinformation I mean how could marry
hemp promote an app like that disgusting
so disappointed in her she was gonna get
fired for sure
Nintendo of America did the new
procedure Pride Month
oh god I wish I was real but those two
are brothers I can't be real happy
incest month no that can't be right
please be real
okay it is real but it's not their
official 11,000 reef yeah my heart
people pointed out how he looks like my
arm is just super long this was my mom's
birthday
wait so pubes on ironically wears that
hairstyle but petition to make pair
YouTube release carried by season to add
a hundred million come on please so sad
please I'll be a good boy Susan and
Apple Pro stand or the chair one year
worth of G feel all his marks and bonus
thirty dollars to plant some goddamn
trees girls in science class you I'm not
touching a frog voice in science class
boys in science class our masterpiece is
finished if you're a boy only you can
really what if we use a hundred percent
of our brain passing joggers on my
motorized treadmill damn it
YouTube 2019 is literally just amazing
thumbnails you don't even have to watch
the video
Felix having more followers than me on
all social media me having more karma
and ready do I have that little karma
why aren't you giving me karma goddamn
it
stop crying she's dead get over it no
one has ever really gone what is this
from stop posting Marvel memes I don't
understand them
nobody this is a gift it is yeah Elon
Musk tallboy 188 181 Elin can be taller
than me that's fine choose wisely a
chair or a propose the hint can I
interest you in perhaps two chairs and
$200 what would you like to chairs and
$200 that's a great price why buy one
chair but you can have two chairs please
pick up your effing morgs
okay Iwata a new Apple mug it's only for
$99.99 and the cup Polaris a hahaha
this means our great poppy Gloria is
dead there is no evidence
you have no evidence you haven't
uploaded this meme you know it's a new
form good evening I'm Mary ham and
welcome to meme review oh sorry did I
forget to say my intro I'm Mary ham and
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
blue I smash like and subscribe and I
see you guys tomorrow because I'm doing
all the shows here on PewDiePie's
channel but you never played to purr
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]